hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
2018 was unstoppable for PlayStation
exclusives games like Spider Man Detroit
become human Astro bot and behemoth that
was God of War to name but a few
exclusivity remains the key difference
between platforms in this day and age
experiences we can only obtain in one
place PlayStation has some damn
impressive offerings releasing
throughout 2019 and beyond so here's the
top 10 most anticipated PlayStation 4
exclusive we can't wait to get our hands
on let me know which is your favorite
and about those you're looking forward
to and we'll see which one comes out on
top so if you're ready let's do this you
know where I have to start The Last of
Us part 2 did you ever play the original
Last of Us if you did you'll know why
part 2 is in such high demand the
brilliance of the storytelling may be
the standout point but the gameplay
mechanics the multiplayer experience and
even the soundtrack all contributed to
making the first part of Joel and Ellie
story unmissable the original games got
so many perfect 10 out of 10 scores that
it gave us a new benchmark for other
games to aspire to but I'm getting
sidetracked by history
what is the Last of Us part to using
interviews and previews we can build an
understanding the core game mechanics
will stay the same with tense action
sequences and tactical stealth the
majority of the gameplay loot with
puzzles to complete during quieter
sections following the attempt to cure
the deadly infection turning the
population into zombie like creatures
the living population have become a
little more militarized with multiple
communities popping up in a world
without rules no one is safe meaning the
infected are the least of our problems
the details of the story are being kept
secret from us but we know Ellie and
Joel will return with a focus on
vengeance and judging by all the
violence we've seen in the previews we
can all but guarantee the Last of Us
part two is a mature themed game I'll be
recapping the events of the original
game very soon so please come back for a
refresher closer to the time
Sucker Punch the creators of Sly Cooper
and the infamous series are back with a
brand spanking new franchise ghost of
Tsushima set in 1274 in a period of
Japanese history we affectionately refer
to as feudal Japan I bet you can guess
why golf stops Ashima places us in the
shoes or rather the Gita of a legendary
samurai warrior fighting the invasion of
the Mongol Empire and taking back
conquered towns for his countrymen the
samurai fighting styles you probably
have in your head right now are
definitely in the game but we'll also be
creating new combat tactics to get the
upper edge in battle so those sneaky
ninja moves seen as lower-class
strategies could come in handy
ghosts of Tsushima is both action and
stealth from a third-person perspective
with some light RPG elements but it is
most definitely a linear story with
branching side quests in that sense it
shares a similarity with God of War
other noticeable inclusions see your
faithful horse available to trek around
the open world which will be vast and
varied for vertical travel we have a
grappling hook - and what's the samurai
game without a duel to the death there's
plenty here to keep us hooked even at
this early stage so expect huge ghosts
of Tsushima news this year many games on
the list are still awaiting a release
date so let's look at a game which is
finished it's ready to release this is
days gone the release date has moved a
few times in the past year or so first
tentatively set to release in late 2017
which then became 2018 and then February
2019 but now it's 100% set in stone days
gone releases on April 26th so what the
heck is days gone set after the zombie
apocalypse but these zombies are named
freaker's because the cool thing to do
these days is distance yourself from the
word zombie call them husks walk as the
undead be infected the flagged but never
use the Z word looking at footage it
bears a striking resemblance to the Last
of Us from the setting the combat and
even the weapon crafting system the way
days gone distances itself from other
zombie games dammit I said it again is
the sheer number of freaker's on screen
at once look at this
expect your ps4 to explode days gone is
fully open world with day/night cycles
and dynamic weather systems to our
character Deacon is a member of a biker
gang and gets around on this beast a
motorcycle in the apocalypse that will
feel epic oh and the best thing of all
in days gone Sambi bears conference
encounter meeting see you on April 26
psvr
playstation virtual reality continues to
be quietly given love in the background
in 2019 this continues and here's a
great game to look forward to blood and
truth I've been trying to think of a way
to sum this up in one sentence and here
it is John wick the game your movements
are perfectly replicated on-screen from
climbing a ladder reloading a magazine
or clip or aiming down the sights think
of it as instead of watching or
commanding an action hero you are that
action hero we play as Ryan marks a
former SAS operative who is dragged back
into action to save his family could
that be more like an 80s or 90s action
film love it if you played the London
heist demo he'll know the potential of
blood and truth the feedback from
playable demos has been positive and all
we need now is a release date the only
problem with VR is how ridiculous we all
look on the outside but under that visor
you'll still be a badass a game which
has been lost in development hell for
years now is the Final Fantasy 7 remake
first showcased in 2015 the game looked
further into development than it
actually was
I'm sure you're aware of the brilliant
1997 original version of Final Fantasy 7
or at least the universal praise it
received the story followed Cloud Strife
a former Shinra soldier who joined a
group of eco warriors who want to save
the world ok I didn't do that story just
this at all
the remake moves away from the typical
JRPG turn-based combat and plays more
akin to Kingdom Hearts speaking of
Kingdom Hearts the majority of that team
will be switching their attentions to
Final Fantasy 7 remake following Kingdom
Hearts 3 release in January 2019 so
maybe just maybe the Final Fantasy 7
remake will once again begin to gather
traction and conquer
to a release date in 2019 here's
something a little different
Erica this is not a video game per se
it's an attempt to blur the lines
between movies video games and
interactive storytelling we won't be
striving for a high score here are
flexing our skills we instead will be
watching a real-life movie and making
decisions as we encounter them our
understanding of Erica the main
character is key to how the story
unfolds think of it like a real-life
depiction of heavy rain with
psychological impacts on the characters
essentially Erica is movie night at home
with multiple ways to complete the story
this gives it replayability but unlike
modern date video games Erica will only
last a few hours which should be
represented in the price expect Erica to
cost the same as a blu-ray rather than a
triple-a title playing games have tried
to bring a new aspect to home
entertainment and in 2019 this may be
the year it finally takes hold back in
2014
a hugely ambitious game was announced
this is wild set during the prehistoric
Neolithic period in an infinite world
how can we simplify that you're a
caveman in a never-ending world in a
gameplay showcase back in 2015 a Shaymin
character was seen transforming into
animals an eagle in this example the
Shaymin was also able to call wild bears
and use them as transport in terms of
combat we've seen cannibal camps to
plunder and once again the spirit
animals can be called in for assistance
like a flock of crows or a pack of
wolves the core of the game is survival
and existing alongside or in opposition
to others in the world inviting a dozen
friends into your mini universe and
exploring the endless vistas could be
remarkable but why the heck am i
bringing this up after three years of
quiet
well the studio behind wild is currently
and massively expanding indicating this
lost project has entered a new era of
development could 2019 see wild revealed
in more detail I have a sneaking
suspicion it will
Media Molecule the creators of
LittleBigPlanet are unbelievably close
to releasing their new game dreams it's
difficult to surmise dreams but if
you've played LittleBigPlanet it shares
many similarities primarily the ability
to create and share content the title
dream is essentially telling us to jump
into the mind of others and experience
their creativity unlike little big
planets the tools don't simply limit us
to building platformers we could create
every game genre imaginable whether
that's a shooter a puzzle game adventure
title if we can dream it we can make it
for those worried about designing in
dreams be aware that three stories will
make up a campaign showcasing all the
tools on offer from that point make your
own or wait and play endless adventures
made by other's dreams in essence is
another endless game that could last a
lifetime have you heard of concrete
genie meet ash a teenager bullied and
belittled who isolates himself away from
others sounds like a great feel-good
story already right well stick with it
because ash has recently discovered a
power his artwork magically comes to
life
concrete Genie attempts to bring a new
aspect to puzzle solving as your
paintings interact with the world
opening new pathways are giving subtle
hints each of Ash's creatures have
abilities such as fire or electricity
with far more to be revealed
concrete Genie makes anyone feel like an
artist it really does and as we
revitalize a polluted old fishing town
we've got to be aware of those bullies
who are out to stop ash and these
creations
a game which has been an enigma since it
was first revealed back in 2016 is death
stranding hideo kojima of Metal Gear
Fame is back and working with a
celebrity cast to bring us death
stranding almost three years later we've
seen in-game cinematics and a tiny
selection of gameplay moments but I'll
be honest I still have no idea what the
heck is going on but and that is the
brilliance around the project we have
been told death stranding is an
open-world action game and that's really
it to be honest we've seen a baby inside
a jar we've seen a baby inside a man and
some sort of witchcraft two invisible
monsters remember that and the Bionic
Woman this is impossible to understand
in the best possible way we will receive
more answers in 2019 Kojima has
cryptically stated death stranding will
release before the 2020 Tokyo Olympics
and in the year the new Akira film is
set which so happens to be 2019 I
personally believe death stranding will
be a ps5 title as it will persuade more
customers to get that console in their
homes but I'd love to be wrong time will
tell I suppose so there we have it 10
PlayStation exclusive games to play in
2019 and beyond what's on top of your
list to play I personally can't wait to
take on 100 freaker's in days gone and
of course fight that freaking bear the
enigma of death stranding continues to
baffle us all but will it release on ps4
or PS 5 let me know your thoughts in the
comments and if you're still here at the
end of the video right oh I love
cavalries ear in the comments and I will
come and find you I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time don't worry loves
every day
you